[Music]
taking one last look sir
here are the things we love a good fan
theory and the more over the top the
better
disney fans are definitely creative and
sometimes they get it right when it
comes to their predictions
let's take a look at sometimes when fans
predicted the future when it came to
upcoming films this honor on youtube
sarah jeffrey didn't appear in
descendants 2 due to a scheduling
conflict but we had a feeling she'd be
back and with a vengeance in the third
movie
many fans thought audrey would be an
all-out villain in descendants 3
including us here at the things and
while we don't like to brag
we were right about this one and so were
many other fans who made the prediction
audrey did steal the queen's crown and
maleficent scepter from the museum of
cultural history
and used them to continue her crusade
against mal
if you're already making predictions for
descendants 4 sarah jeffrey did say that
she'd love to see audrey going from an
all-out mean girl to having some friends
of her own
i was hoping you were home the first
frozen movie had us all singing let it
go
and trying to figure out answers for the
many questions the first film didn't
answer
one big question mark was regarding the
fate of elsa and honest parents
but many fans held out a hope that this
would be addressed in frozen two
we did end up finding out the truth when
elsa and anna stumbled upon their
parents wrecked ship which is
actually kind of grim for a kids movie
elsa
i want to know what happened to them
although this proved what some fans had
predicted it actually disproved what
co-director chris buck said about their
parents going on to have tarzan and live
out their final days in the jungle
chris admitted at d23 that these disney
characters are not related
so that's one theory we can finally
retire vampires are used to being
romanticized in works of fiction but
zombies not so much so it was fun to see
them dancing
singing and not eating brains in disney
channel's movie zombie
when the trailer for the sequel came out
we realized werewolves were being added
to the mix
and that addison seemed to get involved
with this new pack
many fans including reddit user u true
fourteenfold believed addison would
become a werewolf
and since her white hair was glowing at
the end of the film this seems to
confirm that she is the great alpha they
were looking for
when is zombies three going to come out
disney's moana broke a ton of princess
tropes but some fans still managed to
make accurate predictions
including the super carlin brothers they
predicted that the ships from the
beginning of the trailer were once owned
by moana's people and were the same she
discovered in the cave
if you've seen the movie you know that
moana does learn that her people were
once voyagers who traveled
all over the ocean which inspires her to
go on an adventure of her own
ocean is a friend of mine the animated
version of disney's aladdin came out all
the way back in 1992
but there was one fan theory that had
people speculating for years
the film features the iconic voice of
the late great actor
robin williams as the genie and he had a
huge impact on the big blue character we
all know and love
we might even call it a one-of-a-kind
performance except for the fact that the
genie was an awful lot like one
particular merchant who also appeared in
the film
please come closer too close a little
too close
some fans argued he was really genie in
disguise since he only had four fingers
and was
also voiced by robin williams aladdin
directors ron clements and john musker
finally confirmed this rumor stating
that originally the merchant's true
identity was going to be revealed but
this part of the plot was edited out due
to time constraints
going into the third descendants movie
fans were eager to know who mao's
biological father is
we knew her mother was the glamorous yet
terrifying maleficent from disney's
sleeping beauty
but her father was a mystery for the
first two movies
some fans suspected that he was a human
which is why our mal has a much more
tender heart than her mother
but one hot theory going around was that
her father was none other than hades
the god of the underworld and the disney
channel movie proves
hades you are the father yes mal
is officially a demigod so we can move
on to thinking of fun fan theories for
descendants for now
mistress of evil is a tough nickname to
live up to but maleficent definitely did
so in sleeping beauty
however disney gave this classic villain
a chance to redeem herself in a
live-action movie which provided
compelling motivations for some of her
notorious crimes but when the trailer
for maleficent mistress of evil was
released some fans were disappointed to
see that this fairy was seemingly
undoing
all of her character development from
the first film ian sandwell writing for
digital spy was suspicious about disney
retconning their own retcon and
predicted that maleficent's actions in
the trailer would be justified in
mistress of evil
and after watching the movie it's clear
she acted in self-defense or to protect
others she cared about
we go home now aurora we all know and
love
ariel from the little mermaid but there
are a surprising number of fan theories
out there about ursula
from the source of her magic powers to
where she got those tentacles
many people assumed her contentious
relationship with king triton
was personal and predicted that they
were either once romantic partners or
related to each other
hopefully not both at the same time this
isn't game of thrones
according to the original script china
and ursula are
actually siblings we don't know that
much about merpeople genetics but
frankly we have
even more questions about the movie now
is to become
a human yourself fans eagerly awaiting
sequels is nothing new but incredibles
fans waited a long
time for another movie it took over a
decade to get another glimpse of this
crime fighting family and tumblr user
sophocles suspected the original release
date was going to pay homage to one of
the syndromes lines from the first film
too late 15 years too late
the incredibles had its general release
in the united states on november 5th
2004 and its sequel was set to come out
on june 21st
2019 which would have been 15 years
later
but unfortunately we ended up missing
out on this payoff since incredibles 2
ended up swapping dates with toy story 4
since that movie needed a script
makeover
we were so close to some serious
foreshadowing but at least we finally
got a sequel
mulan is a disney princess that many
fans feel is underrated
after all many of the classic princesses
focused on finding dates while mulan
went out and saved
all of china so while we were thrilled
to see her in the live-action remake
many fans couldn't help but notice the
trailer was missing a particular talking
red dragon
immediately people were upset about the
assumption that mushu wouldn't be in the
live-action adaptation
a fact which disney later confirmed
according to director nikki carro
she went for a more realistic version of
the story which means
no songs or talking dragons not to
mention the fact that mushu didn't go
over well with chinese audiences the
first time around
no disrespect to the first three toy
story movies but they follow a fairly
predictable formula overall
the toys leave andy's room and then have
to fight to get back home
the circumstances are different enough
to be interesting each time but redditer
you slash gaming tater tot worried that
this would be woody's final trip
out into the world and that he wouldn't
return with his fellow toys
who needs a kid's room when you can have
all of
this and of course that's exactly what
ended up happening
even though andy was out of the picture
the rest of the toys returned to bonnie
while woody opted to stay on the lam
well not literally there are tons of
great fan theories out there about
monsters inc
including which predicts that the little
girl boo grows up to become the witch
from brave
unfortunately that one hasn't been
confirmed yet but this one from redditer
you cyberhusky 58 has
they theorized that the cda always knew
humans weren't really toxic
even if the rest of the monsters
believed otherwise this is based on the
fact that ross wasn't afraid of boo and
eventually let sully say goodbye without
any kind of safety precautions
one of the dvd extras confirmed that the
monsters scared humans for revenge
and not because they thought they were
dangerous in fact the monsters were once
humans who were shunned and then turned
into the fun fanciful creatures we saw
in the movie
based on the history the cda clearly
knew there was
no real reason to fear humans
when actor brenton thwaites signed on to
pirates of the caribbean dead men tell
no tales
fans suspected he was playing a
character we'd seen before
during the post-credits scene of at
world's end we got a glimpse of will
turner and elizabeth swann's son for the
first time and many predicted he would
return
in dead men tell no tales henry turner
was a part of this story portrayed by
brenton and he had a much bigger role
this time around
in the incredibles we saw a ton of
modern and even futuristic technology
which led some fans to assume that the
story was set in the present day
or at some point in the future but
others noticed the fact that mr
incredible reads a newspaper from 1962
and that many aesthetic elements of the
film do not seem to coincide with the
60s
according to producer john walker the
movie was created to be
an early 60s version of the future with
many
older looking elements being inspired by
director bad bird's love of comic books
from the time period
so whether you thought this movie takes
place in the past or the future
you were kind of right virtually
indestructible and machine washable
darling that's a new feature
twitter user elizabeth purvis shared a
theory about guardians of the galaxy vol
2 that her seven-year-old daughter came
up with
this clever kid asked if the pot groot
eats candy out of was the same one he
grew up in during the previous film
not only did director james gunn confirm
it but he gave the seven-year-old full
credit for coming up with the idea
that's right no tony stark and peter
parker officially met for the first time
in captain america civil war
yet fans suspected they actually met
years earlier
during iron man 2. tony saved a young
child wearing an iron man mask that some
thought was actually a young spider-man
this easter egg was confirmed by tom
holland who said it came
straight from marvel studios head
himself
nice work kid we waited for multiple
movies to find out the identity of rey's
parents and when the trailer for star
wars the rise of skywalker premiered
and we heard the unmistakable laugh of
the emperor palpatine
it almost seemed too strange to be true
[Laughter]
among the many many theories out there
was the idea that rey was descended from
the famous sith lord himself
in the rise of skywalker palpatine
revealed that he was rey's grandfather
although their family reunion was less
than heartwarming
are there any other fan theories lurking
out there just waiting to be confirmed
let us know which disney details you
want to see included in future films in
the comments section
and don't forget to click that subscribe
button for more new videos from
us here at the things thanks for
watching